with our coverage of the coronavirus
today the deadline for thousands of
hospitality and casino workers to show
proof of vaccination that's right that
policy and the deadline put in place by
mgm resorts as well as the west gate
hector mejia on the strip this morning
tracking the latest hector the employees
knew it was coming but it is a mandate
that's true so it's no surprise this
morning and the requirement only applies
to salaried employees and all new hires
at mgm resorts properties all across the
las vegas strip including the excalibur
which you see right behind us here
across the strip and mgm resorts the
state's largest employer told their
employees back in august in a memo
so they knew this was coming and again
the mandate applies to all mgm sally
reed employees and new hires as
condition of employment however hourly
employees are required to provide proof
of vaccination or choose to pay 15
dollars weekly and get tested the west
gate also has an october 15th deadline
but that resort is making it mandatory
for all of the team members unless they
have proof of medical exemptions and
other companies here on the las vegas
strip have similar policies including
resorts world and wynn resorts reporting
live on the las vegas strip hector mejia
live local now